papa tu as lu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en vertu d'avoir honte a choisi que des
filles
bon déjà ça va donner une indication ça
quand même oui tu es prêt corte banier
devrait venir
elle vient de loin
[Musique]
et
c'est la belle italienne à ceux qui
comment elle s'appelle naminé nationale
voilà et le titre du morceau
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas
non
il faut pas longtemps la c4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cemex non c'est une heure si toi tu es
qui toi qui dois pouvoir d'achat gipa un
fascicule abonnés
ça collait bien une belle comment la
touche et le clame me dis plus haut
point de mise pour vivre par là ça ça je
vais pas te le dire mais je te regarde
souffrir tranquillement je me régale
c'est cela même si c'est pas un
mannequin en garde à l'écouté
mais je connais cette chanson par coeur
mais l'a écouté ouais s'appelle en bonis
noms du web
[Applaudissements]
ça fait pas ça pour ça qu'elle a chanté
un truc comme ça c'est myriam makeba la
version originale c'est sûr mais ça en
français cette ville
[Musique]
zizou pour les mises pour vivre ça se
veut pas te le dire mais je te regarde
souffrir tranquillement je me régale
c'est cela même si c'est pas un
mannequin en garde à l'égout card mais
je connais cette chanson par coeur mais
la côte est encore temps elle s'appelle
en russie un bonus non dit ouais ça fait
pas ça pour ça qu'elle a chanté un truc
comme ça passe et miriam makeba la
version originale c'est sûr mais ça en
france smp on ne souffle pas nonchalante
connais pas non non non mais j'ai pas
mes messages et la tap tap
ah oui vas y tonton bouba d'accord mais
moi je croyais qu'on était tu parlais
dans le passé là on sait que ce pétrole
alors oui jamais vu ça c'est la première
fois
comme tu as beaucoup traîné ou saint
benoît dans tanger le temps on va faire
un blindtest jazz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
c'est papa me contre c'est vrai bravo
[Applaudissements]
mon bon train
[Musique]
jimmy smith ouais
ça doit être lui
[Musique]
c'est un pianiste
justement
à temps
on
[Musique]
un peu
trouver là
ça pourrait être
et regardez où ça
des cerises avec un qui s'appelle play
misty for me je pense vu l'histoire de
la radio comme toi sur kiss et qui
passent misty et puis une bonne femme
qui l'appelle comme ça à chaque émission
il passe misty powell
c'est bien ça ne me dire que je fais des
radios sur qui ça fait mal parce que
j'adore faire de la radio et j'y suis
toute l'espagne mercredi soir avec une
équipe formidable c'est une équipe
formidable qui s'est fait
[Musique]
1958 à rome
m
allez
c'est m ouais elle a well as
à bessens et dave brubeck
ouais le titre le titre c'est
r2 c'est un titre super simple en super
ça
il ya blue rondo à la turk elias hanna
elias a jugé ça vient pas take five
[Musique]
texas et son pote
ouais ouais c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oui mais alors la chine je connais bien
pour l'instant si un peu perdue là
j'attends un truc j'attends un truc
ainsi
c'est cedex tél ouais mais c'est un
gordon cheesecake le blabla tu l'as bien
connu
dexter g j'ai vécu avec lui ouais il
était pas comme dans le film de
tavernier
il était c'est un des plus beau match
que j'ai croisé ma vie un mètre 90 d'une
élégance incroyable j'étais tout minot
un grand black magnifique avec un
sourire
fabuleux j'étais j'ai vécu dans un hôtel
rue saint benoît avec lui à l'hôtel
montana
[Musique]
je
ça c'est une très grosse versailles
c'est la plus grosse c'est une très
grosse bête ca c
[Musique]
le passé c'est du rire ouais c'est john
cage one way
eddy louiss
[Applaudissements]
didot his way il faut absolument écouter
la musique des deals with the way
absolument
il a écrit un blue ce qui fait dix
minutes dans son dernier album qui
s'appelle s'en mêler ouais c'est un
blues pour son chien qui est mort c'est
fantastique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brunet rock le monsieur cinéma durant 15
ans avec dominique duforest qui est
l'auteur d'un livre alors énergie ma
plus belle histoire tu fais les plus
beaux matins d'énergie c'est ça ouais et
tous les matins depuis quelques années
déjà le coq chante de bonheur et ouais
et puis j'ai envie de faire connaître un
peu aux gens ce qui s'est passé quand
même depuis depuis pas mal d'années à
énergie et quand même histoire vraiment
sympa et piqué est une aventure une
aventure notre et nagui enfin tu bosses
à la fois sur m6 tu fais fréquentes star
et 6e avenue facile à dire ouais tu le
dis toi que le temps fréquence arpin
score c'est encore plus puisque dans
l'après-midi des 6e avenue et 92e au
cumul tu arrives pas tu es tu cumules
avec harper à l'enflure avec rtl le tous
les soirs de la semaine à 20h tél
rtl
[Musique]
le pire de l'histoire c'est que vous
êtes connu en fait à cannes en toi tu
veux c'est à radio galère en 81 et quand
toi tu étais un animateur du jackpot au
palm beach mais enfin on a bossé
ensemble sur radio galère une radio qui
portait bien son nom d'ailleurs c'est un
scoop parce que permet par sa personne
je sais pas ce que les gens savent
encore moins ses commentaires et aux
escales à aller raconte le nom ça un
coup de téléphone au jour ouais il est
dur et lloris ne font rien c'est toi qui
l'étouffé odieux un jour mes marques en
plus on est resté bon copain c'est
laetitia pas rancunier il ya beaucoup
d'humour oui allez vas-y raconte nagui
il faut écoute on n'a pas le temps ou
plus à payer des infos alors coup de
téléphone jouera télé monte-carlo jeu
j'ai envie d'être animateur td wake à
radio france à l'époque mouais
et puis j'ai appelé en disant moi je
peux le faire que ce bonhomme là on a
éclaté de rire on m'a raccroché au nez
j'ai appelé nos sponsors de l'émission
il est infernal méfie toi et j'ai appelé
et j'ai eu le bon sens mais je faisais
rien à l'époque à elle pas à rien du
tout j'ai appris à respecter un peu plus
ses jambes mais bon voilà quoi
alors on va commencer question 1 elle
est pour toi justement on va prendre les
homonymes du rock
j'ai ce que c'est un homonyme les
homonymies des homonymes dans le modèle
des sites mois 2 morrison du rock'n'roll
jim evans bravo jim morrison des doors
maintenant l'essonne de seine et avait
en solo voilà j'ai comme un truc c'est
que les applaudissements contrairement à
une chaîne de la construction ne sont
pas enregistrées d'evry a clos dans le
service public on ne peut pas rajouter
les appelons à leur malheur à toi si tu
mois 2 collins du rock fils et
unis et de judy haut c'est très bien
c'est du dpt une chanteuse de folk qui
est dit est dédié une chanson du crosby
stills nash & fils qui était acteur de
cinéma dans hard day's night
ils en achètent et suite judith bouvard
à vos efforts il y avait trouvé un fils
aussi
il a joué bezina et après il a fait le
batteur de genesis et après solo bon
mais jusque là vous êtes à égalité ce
qui m'inquiète c'est ce qui était
maintenant on va faire les chansons qui
sont basés sur le temps alors on va
commencer avec toi oui
time is on my side en même temps time is
on my side en 64 je veux dire quoi qui
l'achat du cadeau qui la chante stone se
sent bravo assez facile parce que quand
on va arriver au super tracteur vous
vraiment les mariages alors dodo till
the end of the day en 65 ha
the dewey presque 165 tu sais toi bien
sûr connu à tim brasil tiziana faisait
en 65 sélections ont eu au maire
bien ça pour us en question un avis s'il
te plaît c'est nagui alors on continue
question 3 midnight hour 65
non je t'attendrai jusqu'à minuit johnny
hallyday c'est une hyène qui était le
créateur de la version originale
il sait tout oui c'est tout ils sont
enseignants c'est tout sauf les ciels où
t'as pas trompés ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est là que non je sais pas qui tu
s'entasser wilson pickett
efficace
ce qui inquiète dans le midi c'est quand
on se plante et voilà alors de doses de
thèmes des roachs et djing 65 bob dylan
vie alors maintenant on va faire les
films rock a tué maggie d'absolument the
great c'est ton époque de great
rock'n'roll swindle raté souhait ouais
c'est un film qui mettait quel groupe en
scène mathieu ça mettait en scène un
groupe d'amis aurait dû être plus
souvent toesca saurait l'embargo de
plusieurs personnes de plusieurs
personnes ils étaient plusieurs c'était
assez facile jusqu'à sort et je crois en
toi sk sont là pour devenir animateur
sur tmc jeu brett quigley
alors je vais te donne un rapport a été
soumis aux il faut nardi autre chose je
vais te du rock and roll je vais te
donner un tuyau
j'ai pas mal et s'était fait un malcolm
mclaren vélo bave sexpistols ouais on
applaudit
non si l'on avait plus d'ambiance un
plan commun de vin blanc un film un
blanc comme un un un film qui s'appelait
de rares de ses com
quel était le chanteur ni en scène dans
ce film fit reggae joaillerie c'est
toujours un peu de rythme et je t'ai dit
mclaren arrête comme weeds et coop s'est
pas aggravé comme
harder they try ses bronzes herbillon
toujours au large et au zoo et bien oui
même au standard le mélange tous les
amoureux du bel rtl c'est très très beau
la roue meilleur que ça fait un bruit
quand on rentre tard martin la recherche
du gain facile et j'en passe et les
dames et de maquettes ledit faial est
bon pas de diversion de dodo a horreur
des comme base de toute façon c'est un
jamaïcain avec oui mais voilà avec des
dreadlocks et cindy winston truc inouï
bâtisseurs winston truqués bonjour oui
alors tu sais toi allez vas-y et said he
is high bass ipv6 ouais
j'essaye à quoi j'allais valeur vas-y
victimes on arrive au super pactole mes
enfants vous êtes prêts oui ça aurait
été si souvent c'est quoi tout ça pour
faire l'une est enfin alors le super
packers et les chansons super longue by
the rolling stones 1972 11 minutes 45
vas-y lui avec une garden avec une
certaine tentation je dirais ouais
ma parole t shirt jaune et 35 minutes 35
machines ça n'était pas un but de suarez
ça existe ouais un cauchemar ils vont
aimer ça c'est un mix début de soirée
france 2 minutes 10 h hne à quoi bon on
continue dans les chansons toujours très
très longue c'est pas toi en 67 diane
l'âge d'or jean laporte
cette fois ci parce que s'agit il est
d'ores mais bon je savais pas vrai non
mais c'est pas la peine alors ne vous
dis pas non content de lui dit que c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas parfait c'est pas
la version originale c'est une version
en 72 qui faisait onze minutes 05
ça s'appelle areva des sous ça veut dire
je l'air entendu par la rumeur
jeanne d'arc c'est un originaire lycée
d'origine ça c'est l'original mais ça
faisait penser 35 et une surprise
tellement original mais ça serait le
genre le groupe de philadelphie n'a plus
tôt californie je crois en eux et en
californie
c'est dire que je crois tu sais toi je
crois mais là où j'ai un bon favori je
sais pas quel âge entre 12° prime la
reprise
oui 15 minutes c'est l'original je sais
mais là vous plaît reprise eagles
américains
na na na c'est blake ou c'est blanc
c'est blanc
encore allaitent il ne s'est pas non
mais t'as sèchement nos ventes moi c'est
écrit dans ce qu'ils vont voir arriver
oui on lui ils sont quatre
c'est de savoir les maisons pour générer
sur deux ans pas encore quand c'est
votre cadeau en lézard et je les garde
j'ai entendu parler du blind test du
nettement produits blanche
moi j'ai eu du mal toute ma vie à
distinguer la guitare du trombone ouais
mais là ça va te demander s'il
reconnaître les musiques de pub donc ça
va quand même peut-être un peu plus bon
allons-y alors corti à l'avant
[Musique]
ah ça commence res passer un peuple
voyez
dunlopillo non c'est pas dans le bio par
un café non c'est pas un cas frère tu je
vais t'aider
c'est un lait en poudre ah oui oui régit
les deux parties c'est mardi
[Musique]
tu trouves pas ça fais attention tu vas
pas à maurice lévy au téléphone à mama
tu attends je sors du café peut être un
peu tabou ça se bosse
[Musique]
c'est ça non
il a
[Musique]
fais moi un peu non alors on ne souffle
pas tout le monde connaît ça même moi
oui oui la bière à la bière malgré elle
de bière la bière
c'est amstel non attends la bière est
nickel ouais
oh
north et les chaussées les shows luis et
des chaussures c'est des chaussures
c'est pas bata n'en sachent que les très
riches débats
c'est pas andré antoine damiens
il restera non il reste encore des
marques prêts
je sors de sport
c'est pas nike qui n'est pas le coq
sportif
m'étais donné à l'écrit et adidas ont
signé d'as c'est vraiment didace après
vous ne pas en mettre une facile si la
céleste vous fera sa pensée assez grave
je te signale tout de suite mais qu'est
ce tu fais quand il verra les festivals
de pub tu te fais bronze et je fais du
ski notamment la date or c'est un café
non
[Musique]
c'est un soft drinks
on était
tout le monde savait pas
[Applaudissements]
s'il y arrive tout doucement mais il y
avait aussi baissé
[Musique]
c'est en plus c'est une chanson qui est
monté au hit parade en fait au top 50
c'est quoi attends c'est petit c'est
celui qui n'est pas danone d'artifice
appétit celui qui est pas d'annoncé
l'autre c'est pas yoplait du solide et
entre danone et yoplait à 6,20 cicobail
s'appelle c'est pas germé en a
ainsi public commence à peine à tenir et
moi euh c'est pas chez toi t'es chez moi
il y en a une de chaque facture connaît
pas déjà allumé dans séché le picto je
connais l'aja aurait failli racheter en
gp racheté commencer
comment s'appelle ce yaourt attend
simplement
c'est un autre château chant bourse
waouh
moi
n'a fait
madame awa là ça j'ai peur que ce soit
chez toi
tu vas perdre le budget ça va être
horrible ça te faire [ __ ] par les
associés c'est pas tout seul non c'est
pas capte loi n'ont pas d'enfants at a
perdu le budget non c'est un café mais
que le calme ces pannes ha non il va
tout doucement les fermes mais ça prouve
que je connais bien les marques c'est
pas la maison du café non non pas les
cafés pas grand mère non plus n'ont
encore jamais assez le générique de
chaque vabre c'est pas chez toi ça je me
suis d'abord on est une filiale à tout
âge à l'ail est ce qu'on peut couper là
rachetée l'émission je veux faire
quelque chose
à la cinor
bah ça c'est fini pour lui de café ouais
quand même à rêver la jeunesse car c'est
comme da kg du genre c'est guy jeannard
10 ans joue à quoi d'ardents qui me
déguise un arbitre annonce et les
lunettes noires pour tous les gagnants
d'abord parce que j'ai gagné là non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
comme tu es un as de la guitare on t'a
pris que des guitar hero france soir
[Musique]
a reconnu ouais c'est qui ces jimi
hendrix ben brik c'est quand même le
mais vraiment révolutionnaire église a
donc tout le monde connaît tout le monde
paye c'est sûr
[Musique]
c'est le plein du coup de pied jeudi en
grèce c'est une raillerie s'est jetée
ouest c'est super chouette et honoraient
mais qui joue je ne sais quel moment
c'est sacré
[Musique]
à
moi je ne sais pas qui je veux une piste
je te donne une piste aux jo burg
spencer davis group
je connais pas bien à mon âge je vais me
faire huer bon lui jeff beck jeff beck
au saas et invite à la part de l'accord
je propose qu'on veut encore
aouedj mb est une de mes idoles devrait
donc je connaissais pas ça des bâtiments
talus mais quand il va dans le disco la
sas et george benson on broadway
[Applaudissements]
alors allemand ça doit être rappelé
[Musique]
ce que
aucune idée 1
aucune des deux équipes
[Musique]
tabou français ça
mais on n'entend rien mais plus fort
c'est ma course et magna
[Applaudissements]
magma va jouer avec les usa brillante et
hammam en disant ouais enfin j'ai fait
une fois une séance et fréquenté un peu
magma ce pour moi ça aurait dû être un
des plus grands bois et monde
c'est christian vander c'est un génie de
taille
si vous passez à ces drames du dos
[Musique]
jacques myard une nourriture aux
lenteurs sans talent
ouais
[Applaudissements]
à s'ajuster au panel
chuck berry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la premier regard des maracas licenciés
je pense tout bas se tient ce soir c'est
le mec qui chantaient dansaient la
hauteur et tout ça comment il s'appelle
big n
ouais c'est sur twitter
trouver
obama
à
[Musique]
ça vient de ressortir viennent de
ressortir le 45 tours
c'est à 10 ans je sais ce pc oui ça et
marié les garde corps
même dire que ça a été produit par john
key louey ce qui m'avait rendu très
jaloux ce moment là parce qu'on voulait
toujours être produit mais la maison de
disques voulait pas parce que j'en ai
trop cher c'est un des premiers disques
comme ça retour au simplissime mais ça
c'était une bonne chambrée en sortait de
l'hyper production c'était les premiers
morceaux qui était très simple comme ça
et ça c'est une de bonnes chances mouais
parce que c'est après ils ont fait du
disco absolue c'est vraiment ça dure une
heure à pau où elle a trouvé très très
long mais je sais c'est les couillons
new york est là ils ont des 52 m
les gonzesses qui avait des chocs ou est
pas mal on est super étoile une erreur
au club phare c'est un peu james bond
ouais là dessus at on est issu de la
cantera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est génial ça s'est fait en
belgique c'était fermé ça s'entend
s
c'est marc moulin en cours
quoi
brossage c'est parce que cela les
tomates
tu sais pas ce qu'on voyait les terran
lui où il eut bien moi je sais pas ce
que c'est mais c'est un bordel disco à
ben non c'est vachement bien
j'te jure un boum c'était l'ex me
souviens pas si c'était des belges
ouais moscow disco oui il y avait tout
est à saint tropez sur un bravo oui mais
dick rivers le chanter mieux sont jeudi
c'est la mer pour toi c'est de la merde
m
je l'appliqué mon briquet la improbable
jeu
sur terre
deux temps
c'est un noir ça va lui faire plaisir
il ya près de versailles dans le coup je
venais fred merci tu vois pas ce que
c'est
non je vois pas c'est en a eu à -1 à -1
à moins que ça soit la doulou la croûte
chez ou way
ses crochets ces querelles justicier
ouais mais moi je connais pas trop là ce
genre de
tu vois le genre je vois les gens
changer
[Musique]
c'est jay l and click a écrit ça tu
connais j'ai quand même
[Musique]
non
ce soir
ça serait pas la petite soeur de lio à
ces gens ces genres sait plus gérer
aussi ne regarde pas portugaise mais
enfin tu verra son nom elle et du sud
[Musique]
c'est par jil caplan non c'est pas jil
caplan ces gens
viva chile paul c'est pas les beatles
tu vois pas qui c'est non je donne ma
langue au ras ouais on lui
c'est à nice et alvin a très bien tu
vois un peu cher pierre et gilles enfin
tu voir et ray allen ce qui gomme c'est
bon c'est bon ça 13 de toute façon lui
écrit des super musique à nadia rien à
dire voir le suivant mais là
avec c
merci
zuma qui s'est aggravée mais je pense
que c'est taxi girl
c'est ça et le titre c'est quoi
sont pas fait chier remarquer les
chercher mais normalement oui non si ça
y est c'est encore routier
le piège de ces qu'est ce qu'il a de
plus que moi ce n'est grené gros là
ouais alors que bon alors que rien on
l'applaudît
et
jamie way you lie
j'ai dit
a plus eu à tout ce qu'elle avait des
méchas c'est quoi le dit c'est que ce
rapport ce qu'elle est
allez vas-y payet
on voit jamais mais lire déjà alors
comment définir
c'est pour la vie
métal
[Musique]
nous moi
[Applaudissements]
haas a calé
ouais
il y a
mais non jean becker
les jeunes
mais pas cette liste
c'est les stones ouais ouais
et c'est inquiétant j'ai essayé de te
planter avec un pirate
c'est pour ça qu'il est rouge
cp lys et matelas non mais kg an mal an
je m'appelle eaux vives à l'économie
bien tu me tiens tu patines était
d'accord
seulement une et
je vous aime bien mais pas de trèfle
marion m'a rien dit
non
les 4300 loyalistes du lac albert
je crois que j'ai été à voir et j'ai pas
regardé ça n'empêche pas l'état voir si
c'est 1
ça y est on
ah si vous pouvez passer assez grand
[Musique]
côté style des guitaristes
garde le gap year connais les gens que
vous proposez
la baisse annoncée avant et après
ouais ça laisse alors césar des beatles
comme tu es fort je te mets des piats tu
vends mon
c'est bien pas comprendre
lol le
mort se repaissaient jal unifie are your
way
allez tiens bloqués
m
[Musique]
tout le monde
pourquoi sélection de bravo c'est ce qui
s'est passé cette chanson je trouve ça
complètement injuste à voix basse que je
trouve injuste c'est bien tu peux
baisser encore merci non ce que je
trouve injuste c'est que bon c'est
d'abord qu'on attaque on attaque et kung
fu dans l'air en ce moment là la
carrière d'une artiste et que monsieur
jacques lang le fasse rien en ce moment
pour respecter notre droit d'expression
est là et notre liberté d'écrire 68
dixon l'arrivée du as-tu fait l'olympia
avec une chanson il ya un mec qui décide
qu'on n'a pas le droit de parler je sais
pas moins de on n'a pas droit dire le
mot con par exemple et qui tu menaces de
mort
mais la pauvre qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'elle fasse c'est normal qu'elle ait
retiré cette chance tu penses mais bien
sûr c'est normal et c'est normal tu
trouves que les magasins comme mega
store où les caméras ça c'est pas normal
ça c'est pas normal mais moi je pense
que c'est normal qu'elle tienne à sa
peau et à la peau de ses musiciens
cela dit ce que je trouve anormal c'est
que le ministre de la culture ne fasse
absolument rien et qu'ils accèdent
montagne cette rencontre à sens et
dérangeante langues
bon on continue
dès qu'un brin de soleil dans chagrin
alors là tu aimes les basques ont marre
des soins cette approche qu'il soit
achevé
tu fumes gauche a transformé et dix ans
je n'ai pas besoin moi je fonce je ne
sais pas qui c'est je sais pas georgette
lemaire royaume
bien qu'il ait voix papa tu déjà comme
aby chakra jeu libre
alors continue à s'estomper
oui mais c'est pas gianna nannini je
t'avertis et tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me attentes
je veux pas tu vois pas bien je m'engage
prochaine grande cantatrice costil non
monsieur je veux pas dire de conneries
parce que quand on dit des conneries là
dessus on en dit decrauzat je préfère
pas en dire tu vois vas-y qu'est ce que
c'est ben oui d'abord c'est la callas
balazs voulait dire mais n'étant pas
scier je recommande par la callas
si l'entretoit je me suis branché pour
prendre une nouvelle du soir tu n'es
plus belles chansons que les familles
vers celle là qui bien ma veine software
le président est sympa de faire ce délit
en trente ans la voix d'un des endroits
mais c'est celle là ça bravo bravo sa
soeur a eu avec la sortie ouais on parle
de bayssan ans tu t'appelles comment
tomber sa série 7 regarde toujours en ça
devrait perdre toujours pas quand il l'a
appelé centre garde pas celle à
copenhague
non non non je suis là non
[Musique]
m
ouais mais trop vite et que j'ai du mal
à reconnaître le belge avec une bonne
chanson là c'est ça fait au moins la
troisième la non j'ai dit que c'était la
chanson que je connaissais le plus je me
connais pas les autres
bon anniversaire c'est très très bien
elle te fait pas peur gage pâtit donc
bien personne ne nous sépare je suis
unique dans son genre
bon on continue bon là je vais te voir
tu content elles font un petit bébé non
si tu regardes lunettes noires a dû le
voir ça n'a pas souri
bastien se reprocher pas déçu
[Musique]
photo gb
j'ai rarement vu comme ça ah ouais ouais
il m'a dit tu as 22 g l'émission la
première comme ça c'est sam braun
s'appelle stop au wawel j'ai commencé à
écouter son album je suis désolé je me
sers et à la suite de l'annoncé
algérie hockey le basket
lui snap
oui il était comme ans
c'est lui qui a fait le premier bilan
avant c'est ce que j'ai fait non j'ai
pris une gomme pour effacer mon nom mais
j'aimerais tellement j'étais déçu
il ya dix membres de contester des deux
premiers 10 de ce stage il éduque ses
tenues elle nous rappelle pas encore
gaza
iman j'étais chez lui m'a dit vous savez
ce qu'elle évoque notre
techno j'avais la même technique que
call center où est érigée par cissé ne
vais pas revenir
les gars et les garçons bouchers
tu as fait un clip avec eux je ne vois
plus là on était bonne famille avant
deux filles parce que désolé bien
j'invite à dix c'était bien même très
bien mais ça va je
élections tu connais ça toi il connaît
pas en suivant un bar tous les
chevaliers du ciel
elle a eu un petit marianne ans le
chevalier du ciel de 1,2 tête cancer
[Musique]
l'humoriste anglais
triste quand je suis de bonne humeur ce
matin
harcelés comme nokia
sidibe un navire dans le reflet
elle mais ça me tue à dire ouais ouais
c'était un pote à moins bon khalid et
drôle a été tueur milan chedid et sûrs
il était de salon
outre été charmant il était charmant
sétif alors continue cortina et score
[Musique]
à les entendre la voix
pas
ce groupe est de m'assurer serait-ce
qu'à bosser et qui vend
on va plus là
la main
il aa
alors alors tous à la paillade
[Musique]
becky nous mener
pourquoi toi mariano nombre de cary lors
bien assez la planète non non non at a
time when à sa victoire 3 1 contre mais
mona
elle s'en sort bien ouais c'est le piège
as-tu tomber dans le piège sergio un
amant c'était moreno c'était pas loin
c'est mort et là j'ai même
ma chanson
à l'exemple
je les adore charge est arrivée rue vous
allez trop vite pour moi c'est
guadalcanal la salle sur tous les côtés
allez vas-y mon petit hier la route
fleurie
c'est très bien
eagles oc %
voilà ça devient un peu plus dur là
quand même
bah oui messieurs adaptation assez petit
hameau dix ans
ouais mais ça c'est en tant que les
hommes mais je sais pas si l'on bertozzi
et en france et oui c'est le paris sg
tous
je crois qu'elle est
vous savez pas brûler
encore dans l'eau
les a payés pour qu'ils fassent tous les
passionnés flac lui pas très encore une
fois c'est duval le parolier de vie au
jeu très bien aller dehors il n'est pas
content et oublier mes joueurs
alors je pense qu'on trouve aussi
je vais aller
mexx au total à 6 6 à 6,6 ici la piscine
elle
c'est patrice evra c'est dur
roland mais patrice et marianne pour les
connaître matrix et par your way
il est arrivé au fond de la chanson en
traître à la patrie c'est mario c'est
court mais bravo et aux antilles a
embaumé
de lula
déjà
jean
will power
ça pue c'est que la dernière chanson
qu'il a enregistré un arbre dans sa vie
non je t'aime moi non plus
jade dernières photos et les vidéos
t'aime moi non plus
au revoir voici ma sortie
ces sorties mais ils en veulent mettre
dans le prochain blind test on va vous
nous en ville je t'aime moi non plus sur
l'épaule du jeune actrice brigitte
bardot aller aux cov la version de
bardos et celle de bruit
elle en était numéro 1 en angleterre
pour le faire
les abeilles
merci
ah c'est beau l'amour
c'est un peu loin
aïe ça me fait de la peine
la nage j'ai été vraiment bourvil assez
fort c'est bien mais
alors la mort alors promotion de les
jours c'est parti sur les tables grâce
tous les deux ans
tomblaine le bioéthanol est au sol
j'ai pas trop laisser passer les trois
juges à l'audition du père psg à l'abri
ses hanches
car des poils de chat l'invite jurés ce
chrono
je suis
plus gênant
c'est un bien grand
je suis piégé à ces enjeux
qui sait ça y est les coûts et à
l'auvergne
oui à l'horaire
non
suite
c'est un
imitateur au début j'avais pas compris
que c'était son imitateur
imitateur ouais
bon alors la vente hier nous en gagnons
vitrine
alors j'applaudis way
telle qu'elle est
soit mais que m
arrêtée jeudi matin par l'orgasme en les
murs la toiture
bravo
[Applaudissements]
via skype il fastoche et face du rail
fastoche en avant
[Musique]
de la new wave duran duran de rue avec
suez bravo
ils débrouille aussi bien que quand tu
es chez toi de samedi soir faire ça
marche très très bien
un peu moins noir
olympiens gagnent et brest c'est la
fille de john terry
melian initiale très bien grand papier
dans l'actuelle assez one of its own ont
assez du borgne
[Musique]
brillant s'appelle thomas barba
c'est pas que s'est rétamé à tous à la
gestion sera tué des rythmes bonbons
continue alors
abou
ça c'est vrai et ça s'appelle c'est vous
qui le way c'est nouveau signal
celebrate the world mais c'est bien tu
as trouvé on ne souffle pas gros tubes
ont collé la base de la jument des noms
du chanteur ma vie je vais la voir quand
même
ouais
[Musique]
83 champion s'appelle li malouet limal
et le morceau cussigh cantonne à dire là
je crois que le fonds est oui
[Musique]
c'est la découverte de gilbert foucault
ça encore du dam l'agent complètement et
[Musique]
cbc belge ses deux frères mais comme ils
sont belges schiste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
c'est par la suite que ça non non non
non je parle peut être encouragée pour
l'encourager à le croiser insuffler un
souffle et mazouté entourage et à la
flore et la joie qui est en train de se
planter quand même à baby succès
[Applaudissements]
on voit le stand atchykah rome on ne
souffle pas
ça c'est du miroir numérique en france à
l'abattoir voilà par là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]